[Música]
y vamos a hablar de economía en directo
américa de france a 24 donde luis méndez
ya está listo en el estudio para hablar
de varios temas vamos a hablar por
supuesto de este acuerdo bilateral que
va a iniciar que podría iniciar entre
eeuu y taiwán que esto ha aumentado por
supuesto esta tensión entre washington y
beijing por la visita tras la visita
mejor dicho texto progresistas
estadounidenses a la isla luís méndez
uriz y vamos a hablar entonces de estos
acuerdos comerciales que pretenden
entonces formalizar taiwán y eeuu así es
recordemos en primer lugar que taiwán ha
tomado un carácter importante para el
comercio internacional y especialmente
para eeuu debido a su carácter de
potencia en la fabricación de chips o
semiconductores que son utilizados bien
sea para los equipos electrónicos y
también para la fabricación de
automóviles un sector que se ha visto
afectado por la ausencia o la escasez de
este producto de esta materia prima para
la elaboración de los vehículos pero de
acuerdo con
el asistente de eeuu para el secretario
de estado de asuntos de asia oriental y
el pacífico la estrategia está diseñada
no solo para aumentar los volúmenes
comerciales y la cooperación sino
también como una oportunidad para ayudar
a taiwán a desarrollar su resiliencia y
garantizar cadenas de suministro
resistentes y seguras de acuerdo con un
comunicado emitido por la oficina del
representante comercial de eeuu las
conversaciones se iniciarían el próximo
otoño y entre otras cosas
profundizará la relación comercial y de
inversión avanzará en las prioridades
comerciales mutuas basadas en valores
compartidos y promoverá la innovación y
el crecimiento económico inclusivo para
los trabajadores y las empresas de ambos
países
según el ministerio de finanzas taiwanés
eeuu fue el tercer mayor socio comercial
en el año 2021 con un aumento de casi 30
por ciento en los envíos de eeuu a la
iss registrando un valor récord de 65
mil 700 millones de dólares pero en
china este anuncio no cayó muy bien y
las autoridades han respondido a eeuu
pidiendo que no prosiga con las
negociaciones comerciales con taiwán
pero escuchamos que fue lo que dijo el
representante del gobierno al respecto
emilio exigimos acciones concretas de la
parte estadounidense para cumplir con el
principio de una sola china y los tres
comunicados conjuntos
chino-estadounidenses abstenerse de
negociar o firmar acuerdos con la región
de taiwán de china que tengan
connotaciones soberanas o carácter
oficial y abstenerse de utilizar medios
económicos y comerciales para enviar
cualquier señal incorrecta a las fuerzas
independentistas de taiwán tang guo y
recordamos que también el ministerio
defensa taiwanés y bis ante todo esto
reportó que hoy 51 aviones y también
varios barcos pues se acercaron al
territorio taiwanés eso también en el
marco de estas maniobras militares que
ha hecho china como en represalia a esta
visita y pues también haciendo un
llamado de atención para que nos sigan
estas relaciones no se sigan estrechando
pero vamos a pasar a la unión europea
porque no hay consenso entre los socios
de este bloque comunitario por el
gasoducto que une al sureste con centro
el centro de europa hacer poner en
contexto a nuestro público hay que
señalar que a partir de la invasión rusa
ucrania europa o la unión europea en
particular ha iniciado maniobras para
depender menos de el gas y el petróleo
ruso por ello están buscando otras
alternativas y en este caso la península
ibérica podría ser una de las opciones
ya que cuenta con un acercamiento con
países africanos ricos en la explotación
de gas pero en particular respecto a
este gasoducto francia ha mostrado una
resistencia a este proyecto que propone
entre otros países españa y portugal con
el respaldo de alemania porque según
ellos este proyecto que pasará por los
pirineos este tardaría mucho en estar
construido y no resort no resolvería la
crisis energética actual sobre este en
particular días atrás se pronunció el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez y esto fue lo que dijo
españa hace unos días escuchábamos al
canciller alemana olaf scholz en hablar
de la necesidad de reforzar la
interconexión energética de la península
ibérica con el mercado energético
europeo a través de francia por eso es
algo que el gobierno de españa ha venido
reclamando y demandando a europa desde
hace mucho tiempo por otro lado la
agencia de noticias reuters señala
citando un documento a la unión europea
y también un funcionario de este bloque
que el bloque de los 27 dio luz verde
para iniciar conversaciones con la
nación africana de angola esto con miras
al establecimiento en el futuro de un
acuerdo comercial la nación africana se
vería beneficiada por ello ya que le
permitiría diversificar su economía más
allá de la exportación de petróleo que
representa su principal producto de
comercialización en tanto la unión
europea podría beneficiarse de un
aumento en las exportaciones petroleras
aunque vale decir que en los actuales
momentos el petróleo angoleño no
encuentra o no afronta un arancel dentro
del bloque europeo louis y pasamos a
hablar de nuestra región américa la
tiene en el caribe nuestro país
venezuela porque el presidente nicolás
maduro se muestra optimista por el
crecimiento económico que va a registrar
esa nación este año así de raúl y su
optimismo se sustenta en los informes de
análisis de diversos organismos entre
ellos la comisión económica para américa
latina y el caribe mejor conocida como
en la cepal que revelan un crecimiento
para ese país en este año 2022 de
acuerdo con el jefe de estado venezuela
que perdió cerca de un 83 por ciento de
su producto interno bruto entre 2013 y
el año 2021 en los actuales momentos
vive una notable recuperación por lo que
se estima un crecimiento que estaría
entre el 10 y el 20 por ciento para el
presente año de acuerdo con daniel
titelman director de la división de
desarrollo económico de la cepal
organismo que en mayo habló de una
recuperación que podría estar por el
orden del 5 por ciento este proceso se
presenta primero un incremento en la
producción petrolera que actualmente
está ubicada entre los 700 a los 750 mil
barriles diarios o a nivel trimestral un
crecimiento de 41 por ciento si se
compara con los tres primeros meses del
año 2021 esto de acuerdo con lópez
también hay un incremento en las remesas
debido a la alta migración que registra
venezuela en los últimos años y que a
juicio del organismo ha propiciado un
impulso del consumo interno pero más
allá de esta situación el presidente
venezolano también ha informado sobre
nuevas inversiones que estarían llegando
al país y también manifestó que diversos
países están evaluando a venezuela como
posible objetivo de inversión escuchemos
han llegado inversionistas de brasil
argentina uruguay
emirato árabes unidos arabia saudita
qatar
entre otros países que me acuerdo
ahorita turquía
han venido a ver tierras en venezuela
y tenemos el modelo de negocios para
hacer una alianza y que ellos vengan a
producir bueno louis y que nos trae como
cifra el día para finalizar este primer
bloque de economía raúl venimos hablando
de inflación en diversos países y en
este caso toca hablar de la inflación
interanual dentro de la zona euro que ya
se dio a conocer en la mañana del día de
hoy fue de 8,9 por ciento de acuerdo con
los datos de la eurostat
louis como siempre muchísimas gracias
por toda la información económica
pasamos a saludar a juan mundiales que
tiene toda la información deportiva